they've been separated by the russian
state for four months so far but it
could be as long as ten years
thirty-two-year-old artist sasha scott
accused of spreading fake news about
russia's armed forces her partner sonia
hoping desperately that she'll go free
my biggest dream is to see you she says
i don't need anything else
they last spoke a month ago it's an
emotional moment
scotlanker's crime adding statements
that we've blurred here about russia's
actions in ukraine to supermarket price
tags a reminder to ordinary russians
what their army is up to as they go
about their grocery
since february the 24th almost 200
people are facing criminal charges for
anti-war protests and 3 300
administrative cases have been filed for
discrediting the armed forces
the state versus russia's shrinking
protest movement an endless drip feed of
legal process where the state almost
always wins
and all the while life outside the
courtroom goes on as usual saint
petersburg at its finest just don't
mention the war
sometimes it's hard to reconcile this
image of russians having a nice time in
the sunshine as though life is normal
and what's happening in ukraine has
nothing to do with them but i've lived
in this country for a long time and i've
watched as the state tightens its noose
around its people and really there is
very little that anyone who opposes this
can do
but every now and then there's a
reminder a piece of graffiti somewhere
a fountain running red in memory of a
teenage boy in kharkiv
micro protests photographed and sent to
this instagram account called little
picket fight with poverty not with
ukraine the brainchild of another saint
petersburg artist
first weeks when the war began most of
my friends have no words
today i think is conflict not in the
heavy words nor
it's about normalization about am i
seeing the war or am i not seeing the
war
is it close to me or is it somewhere
this one which appeared overnight we
managed to track down hard to see if
you're not looking but with a powerful
message
in five years time everyone in russia
will be ashamed that they believed a
madman and his propaganda it says
dyna magnay sky news st petersburg